Hey youtubers it's Charlie and AMC just aired
a first look at Walking Dead Season 5 with
a bunch of interviews and details on the story.
So this video is going to be a breakdown of
that.
There were a ton of really cool facts from
behind the scenes stuff in season 4 too.
Like they wrote a full backstory for that
funeral home Beth and Daryl found that never
made it past the script phase.
Hello to any new people, if you're just finding
me for the first time.
I'm doing weekly Walking Dead bonus videos
while we wait for Season 5 to get here.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
They haven't officially said whether it will
start that second week in October like Season
4 did or if it will be a different week.
But it is confirmed for October in general.
So let's just start with the new footage and
then I'm going to do my top 10 pieces of New
Information we got during the special.
The footage wasn't an official trailer, it
was just a quick 20 seconds of Carol, Tyreese
and baby Judith on their way to Terminus,
they were simultaneously following the railroad
tracks and trying to avoid the giant Walker
parade.
Which kind of reminded me of the giant parade
Daryl and Michonne ran into when they first
heard the Terminus signal in the charger.
I can't confirm it was the same herd, but
it definitely feels like a mass walker migration
has been happening in the last 16 episodes,
so hopefully something in this new Terminus
plot will pay that off.
Those walkers that they were hiding from in
the clip were definitely headed toward Terminus
too.
Yes they walk slowly, but I've seen a few
behind the scenes images of the set where
they shoot the Terminus scenes and it looks
like something goes down.
So real quick careful for potential spoilers.
Just skip forward in the video like 25 seconds.
This isn't confirmed, but just in case.
As you can see in these pics, there's some
kind of giant explosion at Terminus, I think
it has something to do with the Survivors
trying to escape and it also might have something
to do with the walker parade reaching Terminus.
The first full trailer, like the first long
trailer, will debut at Comic Con.
I'm expecting it to drop Friday July 25th.
That's just the day I expect the Walking Dead
panel to be on.
Since Saturday is Marvel and DC all day in
Hall H. I will of course be doing a mega video
breakdown for that.
So now let's talk about the top 10 things
we learned in the special.
Number 10 - Terminus isn't a trap, it's a
Test.
They talked a lot about the conceit of the
unlocked gate.
Like, why if you're living in this kind of
a world with such huge chompy threats walking
around, would you leave your front gate unlocked
for anything and everyone to stroll right
through?
The answer is that it's a test, the people
at Terminus are probably using that gate to
see how you react to the creepiness of the
flowers and the unlocked gate.
Scott Gimple pointed out that there were roof
snipers and the Terminus people clearly have
been doing whatever it is they're doing for
a long time.
So they have the routine down cold.
I think the interesting question is what are
a few ways you could fail the test, clearly
Rick failed.
Guns were drawn and he saw everyone wearing
the survivor's gear.
Number 9 - Not All the People At Terminus
Are Creepy Cannibals
Gimple definitely danced around the Cannibal
question, he didn't say flat out yes or no.
But he gave this weird Luke Skywalker Stormtrooper
analogy.
There were a few funny Star Wars references
during the special.
He said that had Luke be allowed to got the
academy in episode 4 like he wanted, he'd
have become a Stormtrooper and worked on the
Death Star like any other person.
That would have made him a bad person, it
would just have become his reality and he
would have gone on making decisions using
the same logic he did back on Tatooine.
What I think that means is that a lot of the
people living at Terminus aren't creepy cannibals,
it's just that due to circumstances they find
themselves surviving on the only thing available.
They don't believe in what they're doing in
a creepy philosophical way, they're just trying
to survive.
Bottom line, they're not evil, they're victims
of circumstance just like the survivors.
And even though Grimple wouldn't confirm people
were being eaten.
Look at these freaking bones on the ground.
Come on' what else could they be.
Number 8 - The Premiere will be explosive.
I know a lot of you guys were theorizing Morgan
would return and save them some how or Carol
and Tyreese would show up and do something.
Both are possible, we did see the Walker Parade,
so that could be a factor.
But I'm not expecting the survivors to escape
Terminus right away.
I just think they'll get out of that train
car in those first two episodes.
And yes, all the survivors in there are turning
into a pack of wild dogs, but I don't think
getting out of train car "A" is going to be
just a physical fight.
I think they'll try to use Eugene's cure or
the lie that is the cure.
He's a pretty fast talker and that mullet
is surprisingly disarming.
Lauren Cohan and the producers just kept saying
that the early episodes would be crazy and
then there'd be a left turn, then crazy again,
then another left turn.
I just feel like they'll talk their way out
of the train, then discover all the cannibalism,
then freak out again and carol and tyreese
will show up.
Number 7 - People that we didn't think were
badass, get to be badass.
Of all the people in the train car Lauren
Cohan could have been talking about, I think
she was referring to was Tara.
No matter what I just don't equate Eugene
with potential badass.
Tara on the other hand is one of those people
who's been like a deer caught in the headlights.
She got injured on the way to Terminus and
she's been super depressed about the whole
Governor thing so I'm really hoping to see
her get some hero moments in the premiere.
Aisha Tyler was talking about the Three Questions.
It's all about weeding out the weak people,
the ones that don't have the potential to
survive or contribute to everyone's survival.
Tara seems like someone who will get there,
she just hasn't been pushed over the edge
far enough.
I think the train car will be that push, I
want to see her go crazy on some Terminus
people.
Number 6 - We will learn what happened to
Beth quickly
That is to say we won't have to wait long.
I don't know if she's going to be in the first
episode, but it sounds like she they're saying
we'll know what's up really soon.
Last year I saw a lot of rumors for her character
arc this season.
They just said that she would be turning into
more of a leader.
Which fits with Lauren Cohan's comments that
people previously not seen to be badass, will
be badass.
Beth was getting pretty mean with Daryl's
crossbow until she got snatched.
Supposedly, she's going to show up somewhere
outside of Terminus.
It may or may not be with Seth Gilliam's new
character, the father Gabriel person we've
seen on the set.
Number 5 - The Funeral Parlor was not a trap
I loved the explanation that it belonged to
this very nice funeral director who was just
cleaning up bodies and burying them until
one day he just got killed on one of his runs.
They cut it out during the script phase, so
it was never filmed, but I think that means
the dogs we heard and Beth's kidnapping were
unrelated.
No one was using the house as a way to trap
people and take them to Terminus.
The thing that really set off those rumors
was all the food there.
And the fact it looked so organized.
Not at all what we saw in the other homes
people went in during the season.
Number 4 - They'll be jumping around in the
comics, it's not all going to be a linear
adaptation.
Right now where we are in the show is right
around where the Hunters appear in the comics.
But Gimple said that they were going to do
a scene from way way back in the comics too,
so it's not like you can just go forward one
issue of the comic for each episode.
That's not a huge surprise, since they change
stuff from the comics all the time.
And even when they do straight up adaptations,
like Rick biting that guys neck.
It's not exactly like it is in the comics.
I am really curious what that scene is, the
one from way way back.
It might be a flashback scene because they
did a lot of of those in season 4.
I think my favorite was Michonne's when she
was thinking about her life when Andre was
still alive.
Number 3 - Rick Will Let A Little of The Governor's
viciousness in
They spent a lot of time talking about the
similarities between Rick and the Governor
and made it sound like if the Governor hadn't
lost his daughter.
He'd have made a better leader than Rick.
Rick's biggest problem according to Gimple
is that he makes too many decisions based
on emotions.
He doesn't have that creepy calmness that
Gareth is giving off.
And now that he's just bit someone's ear off
and killed the famer Rick inside him, he's
probably going to get even crazier.
Not like looney tunes crazy, just much quicker
to take violent action.
Number 2 - Terminus will be the biggest threat
the survivors have faced.
I was surprised when they said that, because
the Governor and Woodbury were a pretty huge
threat and that tank assault last season was
a pretty big deal.
The reason they gave for the comment was that
the Terminus people have a well oiled system
for processing people and threats it seems.
I just wonder how they'll deal with that giant
walker parade that Carol and Tyreese are bringing.
No amount of roof snipers will be able to
stop that.
and my number 1 thing - Gareth is explained
Andrew West had that really cool interview
where he spelled Gareth out pretty clearly.
He's going to try and open the survivors up
to this new way of life and what life can
be in the world they're living in.
That sounded really hippy new agey and weird.
But what I think it means is that yes, he's
a cannibal and he's going to try and get everyone
to go cannibal, just like a vegan would try
to convince you it's way healthier than not
eating animal protein.
And he's going to try and get everyone hyped
about the weird co-op sustainable community
he's got going at Terminus.
It sounds a lot like he's a creepy cult leader
who's going to try to brainwash them into
cannibalism.
But let me know what your favorite moment
was during the special, and about that new
footage of Carol's group.
What do you think they're going to do when
they get to Terminus?
I'm betting on them unleashing walkers on
the fences, just like the walkers started
taking down fences at the prison.
I will be doing a Q&A for this tomorrow, Be
sure to subscribe to get it.
Feel free to suggest a bonus topic if there's
something you want to learn more about.
Right now click here to get that, I'll add
that annotation as soon as I post it.
And Click here to learn all about the new
Season 5 Characters.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!